good evening everybody thank you so much
I'll just start by asking perfect you
provide babe you can answer its models
but silent problem oh we're not checking
licenses but please notice meeting will
be audio recorded should we be required
to evacuate the building would you
please mr. while absorbers requires a
staircase please hold the phone camera
intensive care are well also if any
money than able to the stand could they
please allow others to exeter them
before they go too far expect all that
they can then be given assistance our
sentry point will be in public car parks
and size of the civics weeks please do
not delay your recreations collect any
belongings please deliver terms the
building until completions do so by
council staff and Moodle the agenda item
12 projects routers we have a project
from alpha radical gooding and cancer
little skill and we have America's
substitute for counselor Gooding Indian
religious no members attending we have
cancer mrs. high-camp flirt bearing caps
lezonly item midwives number three which
is meant as an inky adult on the sense
of potpourri there are a couple of
amendment limits which I would ask
members to just agree the first 11 that
counselors James Newport was not showing
via visiting member and should have been
second point that counselor London
apologies will not notice which they
should have been chairman can I come in
here please
i also have an issue in relation to the
18 and the statement that's made at the
end of the minute which says members
expressed disappointment that the Pope
area how to the community had not
attending the meeting this would be fed
back to all the portfolio holdings by
the managing director I need to speak to
that because I just wonder how accurate
that might actually use that comment I
listened to the recording of the meeting
and I heard the voice only of the chain
on that recording is making statements
statements about my having been invited
and my failure to attend either this
meeting all the November matings and
once again giving very late apologies
which is not acceptable and you said
Modern Art unless I'm missing something
on that recording I did not hear any
other members think so should the minute
actually read the Chairman expressed
disappointment with my question but also
the Chairman's payment another true
reflection of the situation and put the
rest of state but not being invited the
Chairman's words not mine to attend
either the meeting in November or
februari neither had i given apologies
for either extremely late or otherwise
because i think you did not need to i do
need to put the right misunderstanding
that the members of this committee fell
accounts is than any other member of the
public who listen to recording a meeting
may now have this is now on public
record and does not reflect well on this
council i was chairman of review
committee for six years and I'm
perfectly aware of the Constitution and
a procedure for requesting the
attendance for portfolio holder a
committee meeting Olivia's not surprised
German did not appear to be aware of
this procedure for his committee which I
can only assume led to his subsequent
outpouring of the februari meeting
a few days after the meeting I did
receive two emails from the overview and
scrutiny officer requesting my
attendance as portfolio holder at this
meeting tonight and the April meeting
both of which i replied to immediately I
want the attendance Thank You general
thank you Michael is believed it I yes I
did say that told me call it an
outpouring personally I think it was
very disappointed that Kim attend that
meeting and I've been told about it the
last minute and I understand that your
apologies were given only day before
clémence you're not hearing me I did not
give apologies and neither should i have
needed to because I want not requested
to attend the meeting which is the
procedure according to the constitution
and your officer would and should be
able to confirm that to you subsequently
following the action taken from that
meeting the managing director has spoken
to portfolio holder but he has also been
made aware people's not already aware of
the correct procedure for requesting
attendance it's not about an invitation
it's a request of Lieutenant from your
processor well otherwise that you were
invited to them again you had given
apologies so my comments were accurate
and placed on the fact that whole unit
and if you want me needs to be changed
to their comments of the chairman then
I'm happy to have to be to the call you
so Sarah no I do want to come in here
because I think it's only right and fair
but I do as pre-meet English of course
cut along as people here we're all and
though they were good proportion of of
the committee did express their
disappointments and in that sense I'm
sure we're all back up the chairman for
having say what he said I can also
record it then I walk I won't finger an
individual member at this point but I
didn't need to listen to the recording
because there was one member who
who was in the course of the meeting was
extremely critical of the set of
circumstances that ever written so I'm
sorry gotta love you I will defend and
it's on the public record and I really
think that the Chairman did so with the
majority support hold the committee and
there was at least one other member
who's both critically during the meeting
thank you only positive we work out a
min minutes to clean your apologies are
you saying that I'm perfect I do not
need need to give apologies to a meeting
I have not been requested to attend okay
thank you like members the minute thing
to be amended to reflect just one point
which was cancer generally will not be
shown in 15 member I'm in fact that I've
known for having and gender I to make 95
so a bit playing decider Kevin so I
probably all 32 care interest in the act
for a number of builders within the
district to do use building control
services I should end bottle decided fix
them it's not secure financial wise
enough another agenda item number six
website 520 safety function we have
attending tonight counselor alumni or
Cuyahoga Community there is enough speed
so it's intuitive hands dirty inspector
so difficult physically as members or
and guests will be aware for meeting for
this item has been missing since
asserting that evidently
options go on getting allowed and
members have been given a poor which has
a chance to review and packages
reservist prefer that report to sell and
just give a brief overview to members I
notice there's metal my plates always
helpful okay and what's being second to
use information except courses actual
included information so if I just I must
meet us out on doing so I asked me to
start on yeah I don't feel supposed to
be good i was working realness and Alan
I think it is it certainly could be a
thing to do that's pretty much the
intuitively such courses that way so
complicated minute sorry only not good
enough
okay so so the purpose of theory taught
and being counted to really know the
program for adoption contributions for
which we jointly safety partnership
action plan and for members to comment
on the partnership proposal to carry
forward as an extra plant c3 strategic
policy institute safeguarding fun for
residents and half AFP and increases
climb or suitcase guarding fun risk from
harm if you're very overarching and
priority includes all things around
exploitation domestic abuse and you see
that I've highlighted in the report that
our very successful joint days of action
kicking around what the call operation
walnut have highlighted that it is
happening without even knowing in our
district in particular rainy and of
course aft and interested crime we need
to maintain public confidence and
clearly all those high levels show that
these areas of decreasing and public
perceptions differ very greatly for this
so another important area so at the
moment position about their partners are
discussing their actions objective under
these three and strategic priorities and
we have a meeting this week where the
actual deputy officer of the PCC are
attending and some of the actions you
can imagine it going to carry forward
because they're being very successful so
crucial crews in your safety going
awareness so that's really a very quick
summary of the report which are home
free self-explanatory and I've got
Fergus with me is going to go through
and list it would be around flying
levels and
post partnership very much and don't
worry I'm going through in too much
detail on secular I'm so not tonight and
I mean you should all get the statistics
and I'll just go through them very
briefly and year today sometimes we do
rolling year but I'll do here today
because it can seriously previous here
which also finishes at the end the March
antisocial behavior and 65 less
incidents fs- for twenty five percent
and that has decreased continually
already out the last few years we also
encourage people to keep reporting
antisocial behavior incidence to us you
can either do it 101 or online now as
well and so we keep getting reports in
but the figures do show that actually
has been a decrease and considering
issues we do have particularly in Roger
and appropriate crime wise and most of
it is in the greens greens that's the
target from last year what we hope to do
is at least and keep those levels the
same as the year before reduction is
obviously better less victims and but we
try to at least aim for the same as we
did previous year and the big hitter is
really are sort of violence against a
person about 80 more offenses although
if you look at the breakdown silence
with injury is 9 and violence without
seemed really 71 violence without injury
contains a whole host of things it's not
just the salts and a lot of it can be
public order it can be real rage it can
be swearing and sheltering behind it can
be malicious communications on Facebook
things like that which are very hard to
reduce and and as Essex Police is one of
the most ethical recording police forces
we do basically record anything returns
a Crime I decline which nothing is
reflected there the serious violence
obviously is longer we wish to focus on
more into the kinky things plan to
reduce serious violence and nine over
from last year are dumping it in a bad
position today we continue with a
nighttime economy work and primarily in
rockford and domestic abuse also forms a
part of that and working with one
people and robberies are in the green
dwelling burglaries far less than last
year 54 less which i think is very
positive it doesn't negate the fact that
you are a bit controlling burglar you
can be very impact us and we're aware of
that and some of them what we've done
with the council is patrolling those hot
spot areas and where we have offences
the vehicle effectors really is a big
184 over most of them or a theft from
vehicle and a lot of that series has
been attributed to the cool part of
about four people and who live in south
end but come primary to washer it worked
great wakering to give me some offences
and they have been locked up
periodically over the last few months
and for the kid getting released not
much we can do about that so they are
going to continue to be your target and
what it has made make that rise in
rayleigh districts and we walk to keep
reducing then unfortunately sometimes
the crime prevention met their message
still doesn't get us to developing in
cars and what we've good over you who
some of those suspects are we are
targeting and one of them is currently
in prison at the moment even though it's
going to be for a short period
unfortunately I don't think there's
anything us of particular note in there
and so what I'll move on to is the the
other bits of paper you had hopefully
this has got the power point
presentations or not to worry another
keep it brief so as we look forward then
as Louisa said we need to continue to
work together we need to hear our
resources are we need to work with as
many third sector volunteer
organizations as we possibly can and to
maximize or effects the first thing is
if you another way and probably all our
ad police station is staying open and
PPC said that last week at this public
meeting here so that's definitely been
confirmed by say station is staying open
to watch talk about it closing and
social media is a big thing for us at
the moment and if you looked at some
Facebook sites particularly caring about
Rochford and there's often a very
negative perception about what's
happening crime answers behavior wise
now that we've got our own Facebook page
we are able to redress that balance and
to some degree and it was set up I think
about the end of January over 30,000
people aged that keeps going off and
only one foot was over 14,000 kids or
whatever you like to call us and which
means we can reach a lot more people
than we normally would be able to so we
can engage with people we can get
feedback and it can also show what we're
doing positively to redress that balance
stage of action is Louise's that are
very important to us and the operation
that we ran in rochford before Christmas
when there was a lot of issues Christmas
here before when there was a lot of
issues is featured in the hMIC report hm
I see if you don't know is Her Majesty's
Inspectorate of Constabulary so they
come around every year to the police
force they look at the effectiveness the
efficiency the leadership how we protect
vulnerable people which also see that
links in the CSP plan and they mentioned
the operation in radford specifically in
that report us in an effective way of
targeting antisocial behavior and crime
and it doesn't mean there aren't issues
it doesn't mean that we don't have to
continue that work with people get that
intelligence from the community get
information through Facebook being out
there in patrol and doing surveys with
you know the local council over there to
get and thinking TV etc and but that's
what we aim for be recognized as having
that good practice and talking about
engagement which is obviously critical
again using is about law or legitimate
see and and the information and support
we get from community of confidence
we've set up a community engagement
board this is looking at diverse
communities and indeed individuals to
get people included in what we do and
how we do it that's the first one of
them is going to be on the thirtieth of
March and we've got a cohort of people
that we've trying to expand in wide mash
and see how we go initially but that's
an opportunity to engage would have some
harder to reach and communities and out
of the across water down cattle point
we've recently set up a children and
young people's health these those relate
to the storage sector we do a lot of
work on child sexual exploitation CSC
and for some very high level means and
sort of agencies are involved and we
noticed children because to come to our
attention however what we want to do is
work with Bernardo's children society
and families
to identify those children who are not
known to us but could it become a risk
in EE rating so we want to do some
proactive work and before that happens
first sorry second meeting is taking
place next week and it was all that leak
could lead into our community safety
partnership priorities and already
mentioned on the following page it lists
crime for housing and population I think
sometimes the perception again in
rockford is at the very high crime areas
but the figures there speak for
themselves it's the second lowest in
Syria for crime for thousands of
population on an elegant Bureau victim
of crime that might mean a lot to you
but again it's that sort of perception
38.7 per thousand of population and
which is just behind others first moving
on this picture of a fourth es de there
and this was an example recently over
the last month we had report of you
driving around in different vehicles
motorbikes and cars antisocial behavior
mill documents being real nuisance the
information we were able to get from the
community meant that we track down some
of these people and we cease numerous
vehicles arrested a couple I think and
reporting more to documents pencils but
that's important to get that information
coming in but then we be able to sleep
back to the community as well as saying
this is what we've done this is what we
can do keep the information coming
through source again increasing that
satisfaction the next page just reflects
what or volunteers do or active citizens
they've started to beat surgeries now so
they can give information to people give
some basic crime prevention advice and
put some literature up in the library
and hockley and build to that clear that
in rayleigh they do it at the larger
supermarkets and they've been a real
benefit to us and again if you look at a
police and crime commissioners plan they
use the third sector if given the key
part of that as well another final page
are just thought of metabolic mention
the volunteer please cadets these are
being set on castle point too much right
now they're in most districts already in
ethics and for first meeting is in april
13 to 18 year olds and anybody can join
hopefully there will be representative
of local communities and perhaps kids
who are starting to have issues where we
can do some diversionary work there and
i did I always wanted the leaders
President unnoted in a castle point so
if you get anybody who's interested they
are still taking people and what I
really want to be involved support and
help us they'll be fantastic but again
it's another opportunity for young
people to be involved in something in
Roger and that is it for me some members
have already tasted that Mexican prison
staff though I have gotten all go
non-conscious to completion sorry I'll
stop we encounter movement I think you
said I'm going to rattle through them
and learn ask the leader and service to
the lovely people responded in at the
end good of a bit of a rattle through
and under around the report and the 3.3
very interested to read about why I'm
crying without injury as soon as I
pretty clear interest in the fact that
it seems that I seem to encounter that
myself and the police are very helpful
and the most help i've i've actually had
is to record what actually happened and
what's happening to me and keep that for
around an opportunity if there's a
proceeding of any sort others i was just
wondering with so many people having
CCTV for appropriate reasons in their
homes and in particular to prevent crime
because that's one of the things that's
so helpful and and also the fact that
people have you know ready access to
camera and video and recording on their
mobile phones that if you doing if you
do if someone does in cancer one of
these public order type offenses or
harassment offenses then it's very easy
for residents protect themselves by
simply turn to turning it on and that
makes it very very easy for people to
deal with when it comes to a dispute
over
it's a bit look to me it's a bit like
fly-tipping and we've gone out to the
public and we warned the public that if
they're caught fly-tipping this is a
very serious thing and it will it will
cost them money and it will damage their
reputation I wonder around these sort of
issues or as we call it violent crime
around injury which is often public
order whether we could equally encourage
the public to proceed to protect
themselves by the simple things that
they've already going ahead and in that
way and if people are aware that if you
go around doing this sort of stuff and
it's more likely to get recorded than
not it's going to be recorded than not
and there's a greater chance of them
being you know for two it's brought to
order for what they've done I'll leave
that with you Fergus probably to respond
to in a minute but I my next question
was about a pound of 3.7 why we only got
three targets and I don't quite
understand why they're fix for a year
when things are so variable so maybe the
leader could could comment on on that
and in terms of the survey of of
residents and this report doesn't tell
me how many residents participated in
the surgery and other survey and how how
many of those were online completions
and how many of those were completed in
other places like the engagement events
the other thing I have to draw your
attention is in the report we've we've
developed a new crime and I don't want
to sound too critical we've developed
the inquisitive crime when in fact we
meant in a number of places the
acquisition prime I I am guilty of being
inquisitive so I'm afraid you've gotten
bang to right
it's actually recorded and you know I'm
sure that's all wrong with men so I
wonder if my girl for those questions to
leave yet fancy then gets called people
protecting themselves anything people
can do to protect ourselves and reduce
chances of them being a victim of crime
is obviously very positive and the
reality is though with some of these
incidents some of them are Muslim are
actually probably quite spontaneous
public order and they could be over
within a few seconds and if you think
about the world rage two cars often
happen somebody swears that the other
person some people do the dash cams and
but the other reality is that actually
after somebody reports it and sometimes
people report it because I worry the
other person will report this and then
they generally lose interest in anything
happening with regards to a prosecution
and so it's very difficult and generally
we have an uncooperative and technical
victim so yeah I would say if you can
protect yourselves then do and we have
CCTV literally yeah I think unions
probably wanted two countries with a
more CCTV it doesn't necessarily prevent
crime it does sometimes stop crying in
some areas it does have identified
people sometimes and but certainly won't
stop everything so yeah p people should
use whatever facility is available to
them but it's a very difficult one very
difficult and interestingly and the
fifth coin Commissioner it is meeting on
Thursday actually was expired people are
loading area information for 101
recorded information just concurrently
for training could use if people thought
their plan to get you know call that way
so he was actually keen for people to
upload information I on line one
the the question about the survey yes I
how many residents donít obey and there
was 279 condoms and they were
predominantly all online there was less
than 10 actually actually pay about your
engagements and those big ones I like
seeing your face two days and crucial
cruise so there could only all online so
I mean there's work to be done around
engagement is returned on violent crime
without injury issue i listen carefully
what had to say and it's hopefully it
confirms the view that says you can
protect yourself but we have the council
and i was booked as the CSP it might be
something that a campaign could be run
on to just remind people well you know
if they get a behave badly and i'll just
leave it in bay in those terms that
there is a fair chance one way or
another they might end up in in
1,000,000,000 or recorded material and
that simply made just simply remind
people of the set of circumstances that
might apply to them if they're if they
think they're hanging inappropriately
around people and it's particularly so
when people are known to to do that and
you know i know of people who you know
when they come to anywhere near me i
know that i'm going to get a stream of
abuse there's a lot of phone in your
pocket i just turned on and I just get
the feeling the more they know but
that's like to happen and happen by more
people might just go in my district and
I just just leave that as a suggestion
and if they just and you talk battery
target and actually and the three
strategic priorities they're quite fine
every and underneath those of you know
last year plan we've got about seven or
ten strategic objectives are under
with them more digitized action so I
just really want to reassure you they're
not they're not our only target we break
those down into something that's a bit
more meaningful for partners to deal
with consider example and safeguard your
vulnerable residents from ours is a
moment it's like where do you start so
they're being objective around Vanessa
2071 and Child Exploitation so you'll
see you know later event when parties
have agreed all their objectives and
action are much more being taught right
down the road between absentia just a
quick question grand battered
cancellation comment about survey don't
say there are more detail right down the
country being drafted publication you
know in that will be and it will
probably be at the next couple of weeks
and the guide to look at the moment why
they're trying to make it much more
visual because what you've got there is
not going to be mean for it isn't
meaning so any one place so we're going
to make a muscle official we find
archives and then then we might even
thing going forward about survey how we
might do that bit differently and pass
answers you know questions throughout
the whole year same questions but
tragically so we don't just do is bulk
one right expendables go on the website
ok Kalamazoo Mason thank you it's joe
and similarly counselor mr. Mason I'm
going to question I 2033 violent crime
in our agencies to be impossible tonight
and cancel how many are just questions
but maybe you can answer and the main
focus of safeguarding feminine animals
from home is obviously quite a bite
gambit and I wonder it with that in mind
as a priority have we given any
consideration to policies for them
cyberbullying I can't see anything is
wearing that but it may be in big ten of
them all their forces
you know physics policy or relations
about any the thing is attending what
you doing it can be malicious
communications are going to be
harassment so these technically a crime
and so I think you've got a crime then
having policy on the majors probably
well other than if it's needed because
you already have a crime there and so we
can deal with that crime preventing that
crime is obviously very difficult
intervention and you have to you have to
look them you know is a vulnerable
person being targeted okay we should get
that in certain way but actually
sometimes you know if you're if you're
being bullied on Facebook or whatever
else you know what you need to do you
need to link that person blockers and
get rhythm so there has to be sort of a
visual we like realistic perspective
honest and vulnerable people and there
is perhaps a danger that's not reported
to us and but again depending how
wonderful laugh that they are if they
need support then they'll support
mechanism should already be in place by
other agencies and as I said if it is a
crime then we were recorded as a crime
we will investigate as a crime depending
on a seriousness of what i say
investigate it will be recorded but then
we have to make the decision and what's
the level of us and is it actually in
the public interest to actually develop
this any further yes I don't think I was
particularly concerned with the Primus
sex believe it or not I was more
concerned with the fact that vulnerable
people don't normally have the same
level of touch self-protection and I
wonder if there was any swimming place
to assist that but it was very difficult
it depends what type of vulnerable
people you want about if its children
for example and they have inputs they
have training they have crucial krause
so they get a lot of information for all
the people who might actually be
slightly different it might being
targeted for fraud or different things
through technology and or even on the
phone and we've done a lot of preventive
work there so I think it does depend on
actually what is the vulnerability and
how do we done a dressed-up on a bruisin
it is difficult and interesting for
children
recognized at crucial crews that would
be an area that even mean warm thank you
Richard thank you very much cancel mr.
Coyne Thank You Joan ton from the tearin
and I got one of my questions because
there's another fish which is far more
important which occurred since of red
beans figures on the contributed January
dates are looking at the right figures
which to me 20 than 56 / 16 laughter 11
under the age of 16 care are a large
gear for under 16 0 the same issue of if
you say ki operate over 16 last year for
people with books into this year North
the sink and the way you're not talking
about the Arctic is here on time I fees
under 16 like coming somewhere under
childs exploitation maybe I don't know
the over 16 or diseased wood in the
National camp accounting 8 17 18 s I'm
not sure how the ancient works only that
we include it I'm just wondering if this
year's if there is a part yes people can
play in trying to reduce these figures
or help people come on guessing or 50 or
not sin cara right people might not come
forward even understand that is an issue
is there anything the cs people do
regarding this that wheel either helping
people helping and maybe it's a
professional giving evidence i don't
know of these victims which seems our
industry I don't know how to respect
your baby it's an let me give you some
men sort of clarity around that and some
of those rapes we have very few stranger
ranks very few in the district to give
us some some of these will be domestic
and rapes and some of them will be
historic range that have been reported
to a snap so that obviously goes on this
year's serious but they are repaying his
story and that could be domestic abuse
historic article views and tolerates as
well and under-16 could be statutory
rape so if you're under 16 you can't
have sex institute as that and what we
do in that case generally if the male
involved as well is under 18 I think it
is and what we do is we record that is a
crime but we don't take any
because those children are about the
same age what we don't want to do is
criminalized children for consensual sex
even though technically it's a crime we
have specialist departments that filled
with that or child abuse investigation
team deal with rape under 18 children
and or sex or sexual offenses team now
calls base a SS camaro stance on and now
even raped over 16 and there's been some
issues identified previously wish and
sold rate and the positive outcomes and
getting people to court was discussed
and what I think we've now realize is
actually sometimes we get a victim and
it might be historic and and they might
be talking to us about the recent
incident but then they happen to mention
a read previously and actually they
don't want anything done about us
they're adamant this is in my past I've
beverage I don't want you to do anything
because realistically we probably won't
get anywhere its historic there's no
witnesses I just want to move on with my
life we have to record ash and what we
did for a period of time was we tried to
push that victim to say you have to do
something about this we have to deal
with your fender and now i think the
thinking is turned around to say
actually let's do the victim wants to do
within reason once there's no current
safeguarding issues once they think
they've bet with that properly then
actually it is right and proper to say
we're not going to push you to do this
you don't anything done that's your rice
as a victim and so that's one of the
difficulties with the sold fresh and the
other is sort of independent evidence
and you will very often and this is
generalizing if somebody reports a rape
there's very seldom witness and there
may be some forensic evidence but
sometimes the suspect indicate that by
saying yeah we did a sex was consensual
and it can be very difficult and the
Crown Prosecution Service generally only
want to prosecute things if they've got
a realistic chance of conviction and
because otherwise they say actually it's
wasting people's time it's wasting the
victims time to it in place time it's
ways in Crown Prosecution time and so we
won't generally take it unless we've got
a realistic chance and so that's some of
the clarity around this
we do a lot of preventive work around
and sexual violence and domestic abuse
and also expensive work around with some
children and funding and the children
and focus I ammonia and cannoli Iran
about new local groups that are trying
to catch children Ferrier now and that's
right but these are people that can be
very easily extremities if we don't
catch the man and a lot of the rapes are
by what we call the name suspects people
from not a victim obviously doesn't make
it right but it's trying to sort of
reduce that gap one of the things we did
on facebook now is then every weekend we
put a positive about domestic abuse
which often sometimes those incorrect so
it can help people every weekend when we
get higher levels of domestic abuse and
sexual assaults they can look at and say
oh actually perhaps I need staff doing
something about my situation and gettin
out of those and I think it's a
difficult one for the CSP we can do
things as Louisa said with young
children nighttime economy is another
one and drugs are sometimes used the
nighttime economy providing a positive
presence there and we've been trying to
get straight pastors without success
we're now looking at possibly buying an
SOS bus so that can be deployed in the
area or actually just sending on setting
up a tent in high street at raley it
nice and wood some chairs with a first
aider so females who are drunk and
vulnerable taxis might incite them
they've got some research and they've
got somewhere to be protected so I think
we can do you know little steps life
after actually mine any difference thank
thank you got another desktop that what
the other person which was very
different sometimes it seems there with
them try two professions we offer you
something about with 5.1 5.13 on the
riverwalk a little active citizens good
second 16 we now have 65 them citizens I
think it referred to a difficult very
active sisters steenpister when I are 74
authority and it's interesting that the
hull breach police meetings rock band
hell that whole bridge don't get help so
as a fellow finding forrester rice this
point which is very good bunnies these
are the object are you aware of
the similar scheme run by the fire
authority and it's interesting in the
room we had the active systems the place
and effectively axis is authority to
free food very simple things yeah who
can even though the other existed that's
going on you're aware yeah I'm family
well arrive at a duplicate I'm aware
desires had the volunteers slightly
different obviously perhaps when we all
join together it might become more more
more coke as to what Nichols will talk
more of the same thing and but yeah I
think we're doing pretty to tie things
better together and i'll certainly be
back to mind we've now but i think
technical systems we've sort of more
weight in betting and really positive
really good and they do a lot of work
highly visible and put yeah I'm can
certainly look into that here we've been
linked together to complete with make
sense of it is very much capsule easily
I'm talking about CCTV and do you need
that fine telling you place ECT is in
operation because if you buy the kit it
comes with it and it says this must you
must tell people that if they're
entering your property that they are
being recorded if my simple bit of
advice to anybody who wants to use CCTV
is still on the information
commissioner's office and looked at the
am what they tell you to do that's the
best way to do and that covers
organizations and covers individuals as
well individuals are completely
different generally than organizations
but that's what I would tell people do
thank you okay thank you very cancer
Stanley Thank You chef oh six or two
questions that have come come up
recently these figures are very nice up
to January have we can break it down
called to me as to what a quarterly
figures could be or are recently because
crimes have taken place in acidity and
the other question is where we've got
the community psych Dean was completed
online do you take into consideration
loans item sort of something
attention and in the way of given a
number that crime is taking place as
well does that community center sorry
what you meant giving desire Venice
think so so they says just online but we
might be safety in their favorite
undertaken by the community safety on
fifth District Council not like you like
some time down is doing do we take that
in the civic duty takedowns open when
they come from the police that they be
engaged number do you take those as part
of the online from residence of
Community Safety the numbers willing
crazy outside to saying that term free I
mostly people are not up in the online
all the time well I think lot people
don't go wrong wrong so do we take any
response from those big with them go
online I think the reason original udah
to the fact that the numbers on the
platform or anything and others were or
your bid at that what is that in future
we need to look at different ways and
maybe ask the question more frequent on
the regular basis to get mobile level
separately with relationships club
statistics I'm not quite sure what your
question is recently they've been quite
a few incidents and I just wonder if
it's got always got sort of negative on
the point that the thing is given here
actually to be a bit more specific about
sowing seeds robbery of personal
property and your grievance burglary in
dreams for nervous it's funny as its and
God there didn't figure but have we is
it although that's the yearly figure is
that is it still going down as we speak
or is it as
so the things you need between january
january we've seen anything said I yet
27 29 yeah yeah best of my knowledge and
these are also just behind so they can
do the analysis and if you go on the
police UK website that's a month behind
isn't it you can look at anything on
that can't you okay for your poor Scott
not anything but comments us today
that's a fairly sweet elated because at
them office hours to get to my knowledge
there's been nothing no strikes no
massive increase line type of crime in
provocative history in a moment you'll
always get things that the Watertown
facts natural and that's all your major
is over a period of a year when we get
worried as we see suddenly we've got ten
vehicle crimes in rossford overnight
which is why I alluded to and ask their
high figures well it's ad or whatever
was in fact shows over a few weeks or a
few months some high levels of a nice
and then we identify them we do
something about bashed and once we
identify it and but at the moment no
there's nothing that particularly stands
out as on increase of the month thank
you very much cooking other people that
indicated situations i will allow them
to speak and i didn't have a couple
questions once else works at Oakington
ask you to the closing 3.4 and at the
bottom it says as part of the plan to
remedy this and you drop in facilitated
what's the council officers being set up
this will help talk improving response
and visibility across the east of the
history and this is emitted in respect
of emergency response time would you to
spell it for some members clarify walk
or give us a bit more detail about what
is it essential drop-in facility when it
will operate who's going to manage and
it's already in operation and
effectively and totally freaked out the
climb when actually a full part the
council offices which inspector fili and
i can only say the staff that area and
where the community city you can drop
their got time
and they can come in and just boot up
their mobile phones and iPads it sexual
user facilities and you really just
really at the touch base so they don't
have to go all the way back through
terrain to get to other cars in the
district and you see office infusing
that periodically and when so it's
nothing more than just coming into the
Korean where again the cup of tea firing
up their phones you can experience
nothing thank you one of the questions
regarding the anti-social behaviour says
here in the same 3.4 the burglary and
other crimes are blown a schism as if
exception vehicle offensive and social
behavior calls are down in five point
five to seven last year Oh mining
concern without figure being down is
that because the perception of mental
public is it's a lot harder to report
crime and that's it's now the figures
are sound but it's being used as a
positive we're actually in reality it
might have been negative because it's
changes to depletion in this area in
particular I don't think so we always
encourage people to bring us we know
it's frustrating it can be difficult and
but now we've also got the underlying
facilities reporting such behavior and
so I think it's actually easier to
report it now now that online securely
hasn't always been there and put it is
there now and I mean as I said it's gone
down consistently over the last few
years and you know if you attend some of
the meetings in rochford and other
places and the sort of how other people
are about the levels antisocial behavior
and a lot of them do report ish and we
get emails free even without social
behavior now it should be sensory
properties or gets recorded as an
incident but I don't personally think
it's under reporting thank you my last
question was with God's resource
implications and obviously we get the
funding for me it's expensive
compliments and the figures are there
for the current year and for the next
year 12,300 test seven I just wondered
is there anyway you perhaps the next
that there could be comparisons included
in it for the benefit of members in
other areas Hamas ABC he cooked just to
see whether what we are enzyme another
area yes and we're we know we can't the
point which is obviously a very much yes
and obviously I can find out for you how
they work that out because this per
population we have tickets on how many
crimes is taking place in other areas
not how much money go you see you know I
would check with PCC office when I can
discuss that but it also can information
okay lovely thank you own cathode ray
hey Christian my question is emulation
23.9 a 24-ton free to say the realm of
the priority respective drug offenses
linking reoffending and a bourbon street
think we know that there is a problem
with radical here as there is in most
areas but I'm just warming I've heard
also would regard to the street gangs a
little games are coming out of London
and dispersing the domestics is there a
particular problem with Rochford in
respect to the games no it's a simple
answer and there is there is an issue
with drug dealing everywhere and that's
for sure and the drug gangs primarily
operates and they go through grades
they're going to mandolin they seem to
skip Roger and cattle prod to degree
that we'll see gotta be there somewhere
and then you're going to sell them and
it's prolific and the issues that
they've had all those great violence
murders stabbings etc having small
spherical britax probably the word to
use and they are now well sort of
integrated in those communities dealing
drugs I'll be partly the issue that we
don't have it as badly and just because
it's localized feeling that's probably
been set up for quite a period but we've
also undoubtedly got less code users and
hard drug users and that is the thing if
you haven't got a market you're not
going to go
I and there will be recreational use of
cocaine cannabis is the basic saying
everybody goes over for 15 seems to be
small Canada's since then very clean I'd
other wine and facing to be smoking
cannabis but that's mostly localized
drug beings and when you think about the
issues we had on handling and the
shooting last year which was linked to
drugs there were all local people to
candy and so I'm not sure exactly why
that links the mixture of reasons
localized alien but people who live
locally less demand for us less money to
be made and they go into those areas we
do have a dedicated gangs unit and under
Operation Raptor one of those teams is
based at raleys sort of do cover cattle
point and Roger as well as self in the
President and force why we've done a lot
of work with the next we're obviously
sort of fairly expert on gangs and they
do give us assistance and because those
people who cause issues imagine
ourselves and also cause issues in the
mix I think it's something we certainly
have to watch and we do sometimes get
reports of people coming through and you
know technology we use sort of automatic
number plate recognition and something
that's very firmly on radar radar
organized crime groups and the series
file inspectors will it of course m4a
six police but at the moment i would say
localized feeling that doesn't cause us
usually and serious street violence and
it is above us getting an intelligence
from the community good as many warrants
as we can and sort of getting most
people off the streets on this street
legal thank you very much 25 questions
monitoring chemical papers and in
catholic exam then it just starts to do
follow from the brt just given a son
it's the street gangs and the drugs
issues in particular how he turned out
sort of coming out mostly luckily a
shrink from London is that related to
particular communities particular types
ozone
here and exactly is it related to
specific community on time coming to
London giving it new communities or yes
a lot of it Somalian seems to be Italian
best yes i love least a month and myself
sort of like my own question as it was
and he relates to earlier to do we've
perhaps cybercrime or cyber bullying
from social media will be many ways
around the table being party to some of
that and I've got particular issue at
the moment and I can do perhaps me and a
couple of my other colleagues might be
able to give you some indication of how
your online crime reporting services
between people have been using ahead of
the next day or two in relation to a
number of bullion intimidation problems
at the moment but my questions you is in
relation to social media like Facebook
in particular obviously people seem to
not make a lot of consideration about
and they seem to be quite free with
their comments on social media and
dancing to realize that could be
consequences to that but some of this
goes through various different groups or
community sort of like an organized with
through Facebook groups and stuff like
that my questions new is how much should
the administrators of these groups take
action in relation to to stuff that
happens on their community facebook fill
their groups and easy appropriately
these theories and
nificant sort of life issues he's the
police able to get in touch with
facebook as an organization to shut some
of these so I externus they become a
real problem and I think administrators
do have a large part to play I mean or
Facebook site not different from any
other Facebook side we have to monitor
it and we have to block comments that
are efficiently there and we aren't we
have do we do sorry nearly every day
we'd love some comments and love people
and some of them are a little bit
insulting someone are a bit stupid
Amanda moundridge do we need to do
anything apart from blocking so nobody
else can see it not really because
there's always people to open their
comments like that you're walking down
the street they'd probably make comments
do as well and so you have to take that
balance Facebook does monitor at surf
and they've got a report facility so I
would say you report it to facebook and
then they should click that action and
shutting down if necessary we do try to
work with your administrators most of
these groups exactly but we can get
information we can share information and
they have responsibilities to the
concert of the same as any organisation
really they should do that obviously if
it's very serious then they can report
English towards a crime but really it's
not something that was it have to be all
really involved in all this is very
serious you know as I said earlier you
do need to take steps to protect
yourself lockable but it's like if you
get a nuisance phone calls we don't keep
taking that call dear but would you ring
the police first time you get an abuser
tompa i wouldn't and I've lock the
number of times you sound a bit more
positive so I think it does the pen but
it does come back to the administration
you have that strong administrators also
answer pattern gonna win and the huge
safety partnership through our own
community also recently facilitator to
Facebook fossil Ganga Wednesday
10 miles 60 practitioners run by an
ex-gang member and operation America and
Fred phobia that they're really simple
waiting for further awareness training
so although Fergus can't go he said it's
not officially Rochford I don't think we
should be writing the fact that we're
surrounded by districts and councils
where is the mission and unless we keep
preventing and education it almost a
primary school age and you know women
see and I want to be alarmist but that's
what courage is a departure is fast back
when tourism and this is about and
getting practitioners more wised up to
what they might be seeing to keep you in
school thank you for the question cancer
Cooper Thank You mr. chairman the
positive cloud cyberbullying had a
family game contact with me one of their
youngsters would be employed over the
internet or web and spoke to them and
advise them to span the police by the
way which they did and officer then we
said ramp to the bully earth spoke to
the parents fully installed cause of you
on your Facebook page make people aware
that it is a criminal offense to being
bullied online because these people
didn't realize that it was a criminal
offense where the young person was being
bullied bullied bullied bullied and sold
acquired through though attention to it
and then let con take it to police the
police went round there at a word with
the other family and willing to stop
throwing one I think we have to be
careful how we tread and doesn't
technically minutes a crime group and it
depends what actually you say and of
course delicious communications with
older
education which is usually to do with
letters and phone calls but it's bit of
steel appliances a message that's being
sent if we put that message on would
have been open the floodgates from
hundreds and hundreds of people which
sometimes another 12 de mainly but
relatively minor issues and that we
don't have the resources to dealers
that's what's that's not what my fear I
think it does come back to education I
think it doesn't back to parents of and
after the children and what we do on
Facebook social media it comes up
together education a crucial crew and
things like that and sometimes nearly
intervention and I would be caused by
what type of message means we pulled up
I'm sure we could put a message opening
because lots of messages up because
there we have to think levels or fully a
dime and we are coming from a bit ta
yeah and then it goes up soon it goes
further from photos but rather like that
where they does become a real problem oh
yeah but it presumably think young
people so you know if the message can go
on to say you know this is an offense or
anything like that to just do to the
people bully is and then they've
realized that there is quan sequences to
their actions I can do trouble is again
how many young people engaging us on our
Facebook page parents wealth which I
suppose relieve some people but not to
kill those kids I'm not knowing it its
blend in to prove crucial proof and it
is so we can certainly do that either
crucial proof the school kids yeah we
can certainly put something somewhere
running on thank you thank you very much
okay members we have gone tom we're
asleep
[Music]
okay really
pretty much already told you so negative
okay I remembered even unto you in the
item numbers take these caravans likes
inequality and like this everyone is
imported by three members I'm going to
handle able to cancel our point if I may
even have to do than just again just
three members and perhaps flavors inside
you having regard to hope I a hold of a
second here so in general very pleased
with the way we try to look at my words
of them we're very happy with the way
the Liam it's going with League I'm
sides of the moment I think it's not
quitting with the officer at all this
and I want to make that very clear i
think is in a very good job i do and i
think the mental all three limbs in
holdrege as well have some concerns that
it it looks like we're under charging i
think the when you read the legislation
is quickly where we recover costs and
only real only cost really and we can
never go into that there's lots of ways
to do it but all the averaging over
sites in consideration of how we are
aware of how much time it takes go
around to inspect sites and also with
regard to risk assessments which refer
to it does seem that the charger
probably if the sport pitch you seem to
be overcharged enough large pitches but
seems to be over undercharged and
surrounded on
half of other authorities which charge
and they seem to charge that we get open
double the 200 pgs for 250 s and
probably getting down for a simmer a
little bit index for the 125 pitches
where look at the number of hours which
is calculated filmin I worried that it
the enough hours have been provided no
wonder if we're recovering the proper
amount of costs not just salary cook is
nothing to say that the course study
include 0 other 0 their costs as well
when average legislation you might get
actually be interpretation of
legislation understand that but when I
love other costs and I picked up one I
prayed and Joseph you've got people work
when a rounded which was then
disappeared off my screen it does it in
various ways one of the one good worth
or was it would try to flap flat fee for
the first first license then a six pound
per unit thereafter so if you've got
five units my private 200-pound feeling
you are six pound per unit then it 100
pounds and a hundred it goes up to 700
which is more than than mere charge and
it gives a Robin get cutting this thing
where you're charged the safely 400
features as you would be 499 peaches it
does give of variability we've seen
these seems fair i'm also on very much
whereas there across recovery I'm very
much aware that these pictures can be
passed on in the first instance then
peach hold peach pie hv pay as well so
I'm quite I understand both sides of it
in where we try to balance if I'm
concerned that it that we just not
recovering the as much he's going to
cost us that's it
okay I mean if I would say that the
officer will be optically infinite I
assume the legislation it gives you the
power to recover for and licensing
purposes I will do you offer any other
info through stroke service request and
even the officers in the optimistic
eighter gone down with shining eyes
recognize that softly its value one
officer Lincoln backpacks is quite love
or quite small so we're recognizing one
also is enough the cop per hour is
inclusive of our overheads which
consists point five and also of the
reactant report back I have to say I'll
sort of their helpful in its bearing in
mind that should they be pulled up my
paranoia or residential property
tribunal in challenges for them be
comfortable so at the end as you rightly
say we have to balance it with the fact
that I have to apply having that kind
but these cost to the children
themselves from every word in the first
year so you know this is a way that we
thought it does compared with some other
authorities as you say doesn't compare
with others bit that's compared with
some and we just made that balance and
we feel we've done to cover the full
extent of the nicest since I inspection
preparation to comply do you want to
come back drivers come back on that very
clear yard I know if you take the title
is very pretty about this before that
still propriety does the are there are
they currently being kept the timesheets
for one of the better word for and the
time spent least a year of them so that
there could be a good comparison made
and an accurate assessment made this
year to see whether or not they are
accurate yes and justify why my
understanding would be that the pitch
phase can get it to the first year that
pressure only and then they remain there
is a permanent thing sadly seen increase
next year they would not be able to
anyway make a deadly profession retail
cost we are the ideas thank you thank
you a couple of members have indicated
that they either want to read the
comment ask a question of runs even
cancer drag and I've got a good question
with chairman on the plungers right it
certainly report how many sites we have
but can you remind me how many times we
have a know how many sites in and we've
got in each category and I personally
don't have that dinner with me I believe
in only six sites we have six sites for
the which are in like the whole bridge
world I think there might be some other
sites that we will mater and which might
be we lost them all on a register in
france 065 involved artifice and i think
they'll i think one might be between 25
and 99 the others believe hundred 299
diverting there's any anything over 200
ok cancel mrs. moment well thank you mr.
chairman i must reassure counselor
voiced concern about the quid Chris
validity of the charging qualities it
put forward I've said that we want to
keep the costs fair but bearing in mind
it is very likely that these costs will
be passed on to the residents we also
want to keep the prospect to the
residence there's a two sides to this
effect also at the moment we only have
large sites but that doesn't mean that
our policy shouldn't be fit for purpose
besides of any size and what we're
saying here is if you've got one to
fight science it's possible that you can
a charge 60 pounds plus 41 carolyn and
that's at five whereas 199 is to come
fisting okay and looked at that way of
setting that these costs may be passed
on I would like to see some revision of
the bank down but it's fair to both
because
the cost is fold over coming and talking
walk thank you I get no hundred isn't it
so it's much too large to be fair I
think the suggestion of council avoid
that a base price is considered proper
price per unit we allow that policy to
be flexible for any amount of caramels
or any sites there or in the future and
the time taken to do a risk assessment
surely must be for 200 you've got four
hours for 18 hours of 200 again I can't
see that that's a realistic time
differential 45 comments at four hours
and 8 i'll split 5200 I'm just concerned
I asset that you've got some right now
set your officers are happy with it that
I would be happier if they would look at
it again Thank You mr. Chen okay and
counselor mrs. 1m yeah I'm just got one
question just say we go with them
pricing that you've got here yeah I was
a like you've gone found three times one
side and of course budget use that by dr
pantheon yeah for the year use that
buddy up because it goes on like erm
amount of bidding for the next time to
get used up on some common yeah on on on
the license space there is used up all
acknowledge something does that mean II
them ghost anymore at least a light
travel on inspection and they needn't
come out in their library important to
come down
they're not happy with that astronaut
plaintiff it's not part of the team two
years at nine students if they want to
come down they're not happy about
something else that's completely outside
they find a nice piece doesn't so if
we're not I'm in surviving alien turn
right okay lean yet I thought I want it
now ok any other members any questions
I've indicated Oh Connie catalyst yeah
sorry urban no chuckles josh everything
okay and based on that information in
members there's two options the between
you can agree to accept the decision to
be made for us all because you can refer
it back to sapphire holder the executive
about are you married before in fact
there's options we have for my none I
don't end up turn on the chipper of
their their observations made I didn't
hear anyone talk about reserving it back
to the portfolio holder for you know
revision in any particular way now what
I did hear that there are observations
about how we will ascertain whether we
were recovering our costs in all
situations particularly across the
larger and smaller side so to me it's
accepting the reporters as as put with
the explanations that has been given and
the questions have been answered but to
recognize the observations for the
validation of the charging structure
over this year that's a hot it's all
that thank you guys looks like something
slightly different left I don't think
there's probably loser entity or two to
send it back to the pro held up based on
what has been said although on my
personal onto I think I'm pleased that
there is detail toiling to be kept
and I think that comments might include
the comments that may now be made by the
cows proof spoken to take that back up
Castle most distillation refer to his
room foundation or maybe with guys a
review for next year's pricing that it
may take care of the actual trans back
to maybe in a different pricing practice
taking on board maybe the per-unit costs
are you asking for report back to
committee I'm gosh are not now on type I
think mom knows I'm on the regattas
observations in everything except in the
rib accept your apologies we were just
those observations which may be taken on
board by the pool from the holder end or
leave / 79 x that i can be weakened
controller scousers s individually were
able to to look back at those s else
rather than you happy I'm happy catch up
on it okay okay but I just recall one
last item that just reiterate that we
must taste either as a cow so who worked
with the opportu concerned that we do
the ladies celebration dropping this one
can get by actual contact
so helpful I feel I'm not an uncommon in
tomm 01 don't you clear the love couple
don't make my education thank you she's
very cool movie ok take on era conse-
hancock exact it are you with that yet
travel
[Music]
[Music]
why my show to your attention yeah okay
members we move on to agenda item number
seven which is the delivery of washer
district council is going to control
service attending tonight we are
calculating war portfolio holder
planning the kind Maggie's Honor Society
of planning and regeneration services
thank you both for attending members
will have had a report so Edison as a
constantly I know she has some MW
indicated that the large oscillations oh
and if we start council is amazing
yes thank you very much so the issue for
me is actually not covered in the report
so I'm going to be asking mr. Thomas in
particular here to help me he set out in
paragraph 2 19 what the fudge disease
for stealing control or coming year but
I don't have any videos for the income
side of the equation is the system
season on the income what I'd like to
know is whether those costs that are
listed which is 150 9300m is being
covered during the year and that we
don't have a loss willing we do it with
us that I'd like to defend 14 and what
we're going to do about it yep climbing
refer to the medium term financial
strategy are quote the figures for you
from the income targets the latest an
estimate so that is 240 6700 so i can
confirm that it would cover the cost of
the service and has been covering the
cost of the service not this day tsunami
okay cuz i'm including on two captives
to one but thank you chairman that's
where else my tracker limited and custom
selection really go a little bit on what
slightly i reserved my case yes I I was
concerned about the lack of detail helix
I suppose up I suppose possibly quite we
can play that detail sideways but to be
ahead detail I've been looking a film
colleague learn an awful word but I
strongly chair of this committee and I
had extensive in terms of mr davis a
deformity Detective Inspector about it
and following it through and
I will come back to your figure out the
MTF s later then there you have given
any figure but this report doesn't have
any figures in it you're referring to
another report I'm a bit I'm
disappointed this doesn't have figures
about the option you've chosen and it
doesn't give any indication of other
options which may have been considered
this gives if reckon vacancy at the one
option which is Carrie ology I think
nothing in here it tells me particularly
you've got to change anything very much
change of fees titles you've said you
want to try new things you said there's
a problem with recruitment you're going
to address it it doesn't give me much
comfort anything much is going to change
from what has happened before one of the
big issues with watcher building control
ears and I've declared this interested
in the mating I do act for a number of
builders enrollment rossum council and I
have also meet lots of builders because
I tend to have a drink man in pub sale
they go to and they're perfect and the
most common complaint ease we used to be
able to find our building control and
then come out that day or the day after
now it's four weeks time by which time
is too late then they will use a private
doesn't roll phone because they they're
much better at getting out not necessary
that day I think that that might not
happen at all now it may do but
certainly not for weeks later maybe the
day long day after and that is one of
the real big issues and I can't see
anything particular to change this is
the end of three years so it's not just
now and there's an instance where I
phoned up in control for something in
holdrege whereas been waiting for months
feelings come out so this is there is a
problem now and so the issue is how why
aren't other options identified here
with costs and benefits beyond this one
how we would dress the big things for
recruitment and retention and why would
it why do you think it will change the
wise it going to work now beyond you
being in and you were here before and
then finally CM tas is that the income
against salaries purely as appropriate
your County for any overhead costs in
there such as building costs etc
insurances and so forth thank you
there's a number of questions if there
was a big thing I mean that the way the
report is written as far as I know what
it won't it's been on the agenda for the
review committee for a while and
obviously there's been other subject
matter that is being discussed or come
forward before I here and over the last
three years related to an ethics wide
service and all those kind of elements
of it so where I have joined the service
and looking at the service going forward
I know that more money was allocated to
look at the building to control service
and take it forward so my remit was to
look at that and take this service
forward from that point so i was looking
at with the budgets that are available
the salaries that are available what
would be the best structure available to
have a service that goes into line with
the other services in the planning and
regeneration department so that we have
that same structure what building
control has been lacking and and I take
that point it has been under resourced
though in the last previous couple of
years and it hasn't had that management
structure in place for at least you know
the last year year and a half sun caused
by sickness but it hasn't had that in
place so and it hasn't had the
management in place at the level that i
want to put it in within that structure
so to have a building control team
leader who organizes the feed who
organizes the the two senior building
control officers and take some ball of
all the elements of delivering that
service we haven't had that in place for
a number of years so probably going back
to when the people considered the
service to be a good service delivered
that's because it had a specific
management structure in place albeit
that it was larger than what we have
available to us at the moment it still
had that management structure in place
and what i want to put in with a team
leader and that team leader will be
tasked with a number of
stretches and objectives when they come
in to ensure and put forward a service
that can be rebranded marketed and try
and increase that market share and
obviously try and get the service back
from from the people that you have
suggested has gone to the approved
inspectors over the years because they
haven't been able to get the service
that they had previously from from Aceh
building control and the ntfs yes what
costs are here you said is it just
making a profit coachable I mean taking
salary for my head cause it takes into
account salaries insurance car allowance
and other supplies and services but I
don't think that it takes into account
sort of recharge internally for the
services at Rochford district counts
okay okay oh just one follow-up to that
which may be to the portfolio holder as
well or maybe not over the past three
years what what what comparison has been
done with other options for the servers
I to say to out of the blue not
suggesting it would be happened but to
southend can you do our building the
trial for us or president I think as
intuitive as before something I'm not
sure India I mean as far as I'm aware
the the options we looked at were that
Essex wide service which at the end of
2006 be had sort of Colchester realized
that you know not well most authorities
didn't want to sort of buy into that
shared service so what my knowledge of
the services that then rochford then
committed that extra resource to look at
their own building control service so
the advantage of that is building up the
service and providing a quality product
again that Rochester can deliver yes
potentially that there could be other
options to look at but as far as I was
aware what is on the table at the moment
is an
reading it given to me was that we have
this budget and we want to grow the
service the other options are not there
as far as a shared service was concerned
so that was the option that was on the
table and that's the option I taken
forward since I've come into the service
what may have happened before and
debated I I'm not completely sure result
practices thank you very much and I've
got a very good question on point two
point seven oh very cool it talks about
a clean line function operability
processing and number two talks about
non-chargeable activities just reading
through some of those communities why
aren't we talking some boat I assume the
some we may not be able to charge I've
been recently ever physically to be some
that we could possibly get there are
probably ones that we could at the
moment I don't think that happens with
the service but obviously you have the
option for discretionary charges as a
part of a local authority service so
there are ones that we could look into
where we could provide particularly
thought maybe sort of health and safety
fire service those kind of functions we
could potentially charge for yes but
that's something to investigate and
that's why I've been been investigated
before digital came for I haven't I was
looking to have a team leader of
building control so an experienced
managerial building control officer
coming to the service and review the
level of service what we include in our
service what we don't include in our
service and take that forward so I was
putting that as a matter for them to
take forward when they come into a
redesign service okay okay and counselor
drying the other personnel expecting yes
another have to format to an envelop
modulation under this council avoid that
touched on North going to skype
obviously we where there's lots of
competition out there with regards of
this service and
I get the impression other local
authorities every problems with a
dessert that could it be something that
could be looks at bearing in mind now we
want to generate additional income is to
form their own company as we did before
and then charge around to other local
authorities and another private
individuals or companies in might need
the service bearing in mind says no
refund routinely yeah i mean that that
could be a potential option in the
future i mean the way that i saw it and
you know it's open to explore those
other options I saw that we sort of
maintain the service that we have get
the positions in place get the senior
building control system in place get the
team leader in place get the vacant
building control officer in place get
the service functioning get the
marketing marketing in place the brandy
see where that service is delivering
then yes if we want to look at different
options for delivering that so if we
successfully growing and then there they
make the opportunities out there but I
see at first that we want to secure what
we have maintaining that and then look
to cry often but I appreciated that an
urban I think yeah Thank you Thank You
counselor mrs. Mason Thank You mr. Chen
originally I was going to ask questions
LOL bowls a plate it because it
clarified where I'm going under 2.1 you
put local authorities especially duty to
provide food and control sir and
question I was going to ask with have
you considered the club in health
service outhouse on that statute is due
to it you can you covered that because
in your answer to counselor mr. Layton
because at the time we had no idea that
there was a prophet element in there
however that questions still relevant in
some respects because you've given us
the growth figures you've not included
as you mentioned to customs denied all
the other had proper papers so that
figure is understated level or project
English under overstated depending which
way you want to limit it
so have you considered breaking down the
two costings for the non-free earning
and the fear learning costs and your
profit obviously comes from the vehicle
if you then know your cost of the non
fear element that the statutory duty
which we have to do if you know lens
cost could you would have you considered
exploring with those that would be
cheaper to outsource rather than do it
intense because we've got no idea what
the information was provided whether
this is 50 pound if completed it's
hidden in ambiguous lien fighter
squadron do you mean outsourcing it for
another authority or body to do that
work for us well I suppose again I'm
sort of probably come back to the remit
that I was given in the sense that the
local authority have made that decision
by the time that I come to the authority
to move forward with a building control
service and looking to grow that service
with authority in-house delivering that
fee and and of course the statutory
non-si earning part of the service so
that's how I've taken the report forward
that that is the proposal and that is
what the authority are looking to
develop a compliant with major policy of
throwing the services or council it's
not something that I've been aware of i
must admit but it's interesting too
whether well actually it's the it's the
proposal that's been put forward to me
that there was money made available and
that's in the medium term financial
strategy or for an additional post for
that structure others costings going to
be lips have it can be and i have met
with finance and it's an ongoing
discussion and yes it's something i want
to explore and have started to explore
with finance but it's something but then
i will hopefully when the team leader is
also in post they can help explore that
position as well but at the moment it's
provisional work with finance to
understand
all those different costs as I say I've
you know come into the service more
recently and it's tough that I'm still
getting together with looking and
finance so I would say it's in its early
stages at the moment and I don't have
all the information that I want to look
at yet but I'm exploring that
information with finance I can't thank
you thank you next in capital crime
Thank You chairman my question kind of
follows on from previous questions in
relation to obviously yeah income
generation is key to the council is up
to the part of the way forward for
council and you indicated that you've
been given a role to try to to help to
bring the book who would control into
bringing some incoming to the King's
Council why I want to to understand use
that given the M it's working in an
existing market and you will try to find
into an existing market do you consider
that there is going to be a ceiling
which you are you know your vernacular
ceiling at a certain level of firm we
say income information through this I
think there's always going to be a
market share that you get and if you can
increase that market share then you know
that be the intention but what we'd like
to try and achieve at that time as I
said at the moment that the first
objective is to maintain what we have
and then look at ways of marketing
branding and improving that service but
to sustain the level of resource that we
have available so that is working
efficiently under the management system
that is proposed to come into place so
whether we if we are successful if we do
move move forward if we do grow as a
service then there's opportunities to
make me look at how we can grow that
market share in other markets
potentially but you know that that's
that as far as I see it that's a later
part of the process at first we want to
as canceled where you said you know
ensure that we have a good service
provided to those local clients to those
clients that we may want to get back
using the service you may have used
approved inspectors instead okay thank
you very much Kansas family Thank You
Tube the 2.21 when you say about a year
recruitment to pay the price like a
moment if certain things that was
working too well and I asked the
question will these what these pubs that
you want to put in operation help help
how long is a pleasant for you require
you internet and how far you got with it
and the fact that there's a lot of
catching up to do mhm and with the
persons that you've got at the staff
you've got at the moment there are
obviously under stress and I mean
everybody knows they're hunting address
at the moment and how long is that going
to be on the agenda yep well and at the
moment those they can post the adverts
need to go out so I've only just had the
job evaluation the post agreed so they
need to go out to advert so I'm hoping
that's going to happen if all proposals
are agreed in between the coming weeks
yes the existing resources as you said
as being under stressed because we have
been under resourced and that has been
the case for you know sort of more than
a year you know and gaps have been
clogged you know through agency staff
members but building control officers
are very hard to find and when they are
there recently expensive when you want
to get them as earners agency staff
member so I've done as much as I can to
support our permanent members of staff
with agency staff since I've coming to
post they've had agency members of start
before I was in post and we also get
that additional support from from
basildon that we've had in place for a
for a time so I am hoping and you know
to a degree we need to test the market
we need to see you know there are
agencies who are out there that can help
us recruit permanent post we will be
looking to do it ourselves you know
through through the means that you would
recruit planning officers you know
through the trade journals hopefully you
know it will be an attractive post and
someone who wants to come in whether
whether thats existing starts or someone
coming in i'm not sure but it will be at
this point in time but i will know more
in a couple of weeks hopefully you know
when we test the market and I know from
agencies that they have had interest
that they've tested the market for us
and said that there are potential people
who may want to come to Rochford to do
this post because they you know looking
to put their mark on mark on a roll so
at the moment I can only hopefully look
at it positively that we will get those
permanent posts in place and we won't
have to have agency staff members in
place which is obviously a much more
expensive option at the moment so thank
you counselor mr. Mason yeah I'm really
pleased I let other members class the
other questions because they've explored
some interesting thoughts you why aren't
you the question of about income and you
gave me the bigger of from the NTFS or
230 6700 coming year and could I on Cal
deliverable that really is and how and
how you know you talked about issues and
recruitment is to clean shoes that
market has always talked talked about
your them reestablishing himself in a
market so you know I i would have some I
have a serious question for you to say
will help how robust use them
and will perhaps you give me a view on
that yeah I mean from the information
that I've got from our finance officers
you know who sort of monitor the incomes
as they come in over the year we're
performing pretty well and I don't know
if that's from obviously the fee
increase that we had for the service in
July 2016 i think it was but at the
moment you know we are we are covering
ourselves and from the information i had
on previous years we were close to
covering ourselves so at the moment the
service seems to be functioning pretty
well as far as what is achieving what he
is achieving as far as fees against
projected fees so income we're on target
because we're using agency staff to fill
all the positions that you've listed in
2.9 I think decisions 2.19 I try to get
to just an understanding most of it
thats good income and we know the cost
paui how are we doing that we're doing
that because we've now got a compliment
for condoms and staff in the department
they're working well we know their costs
is properly inflated costs because you
talk about agency so is that is that the
situation as we see it today at the
moment we are we are covering our
projected income as far as the FIFA
concern so our targets our monthly
targets and our yearly targets for the
income that we should receive from
building control services for the fee
income we are achieving that with with
with the staffs that we have available
at the moment box and we are taking in
agency staff members to deliver that
service at the moment so that is an
additional cost right so would you
expect that to be exceeded in once you
have regular on regular salaries without
without in the inflated locum figures
you'd expect that 246,000
on a pro-rata basis for the party animal
remains actually two to be to be
increased yes the increase a better rate
of return yes okay so that in itself
indicates that this is a viable business
I think counselor drain was absolutely
bang-on when you started thinking about
look if this is a viable if this is a
viable business and we've got the
capacity i wrote this down the capacity
to grow then what we should be doing is
is asking you when you expect to be on
that fully ste thing when do you expect
that to be easy two months three months
I guess the recruitment process you know
it takes a couple of months to get that
in place if it's a good you know
building control sir in a reasonably
good position of authority who wants to
come here it can be between two and
three months notice that they have to
give for that role so between sort of
getting those job adverts out in the
next couple of weeks hopefully you know
then the recruitment process which may
be I suppose advertising for a month
hopefully we get them in place we do the
interviews then it's possibly two or
three months after that that they have
to give notice before they get into the
role so we're probably looking at
potentially a 44 by five month period
yes yeah so do i look at it
realistically i guess you know go you're
talking around left end of the time
probably or before you've got before the
firmament on government so you can
actually say oh look yeah who are now
looking at this to you know to maintain
and improve the service that we have in
all sorts of ways yes on customer
service sailing between customer service
please banging them from castles to
understand that we are giving the right
service in the right time scale but also
be ensuring that we understand our costs
because that costs aren't simply cancel
oh yeah loyally you know Don are just
simply your salaries it's all of the
other on costs that are part of it so
around
toma you should have a pretty good idea
of the shape of the future service as
you can give them a brief i suppose yes
it in the sense that with a good wind
will have all the tournament starts in
place it will then be for that duel and
control team leader to then look at the
strategy and objectives to take that
service forward so we can invite you
back with your team leader medical 500
of course in around maybe november time
i would have said to for it to beddies
and let it be an exact so happy I'm here
it to my god we got a question best
interject on that we have discussed this
you know guys are more up no it's not I
mean we've really been looking into how
we're going to bring this forward
because it really is where all I
starting from zero to some extent that's
the feeling i pad because the the actual
service has been so degraded by the fact
that we with the reorganization we lost
a lot of Julian control start we were
down to three we had one permanent sick
and you know there's a lot of outgoings
what we looked at going through all the
the projected plans going forward is
probably too SI would would be happy to
be invited back in February 20 I think
because then we would really be able to
to show how how we had progressed from
that vice and it gives us enough time
right I would my book there's agree with
that except I'd like an intern report
back there's going to be around are we
going around spokes we can sing around
we know very determined and posterior
South Korea to effectively tell us the
other eventually we've now we've now
reset this business in the way we would
we want to do with
FTE and and it and a basis for
acquisition because you know if in any
way that's that shape than has changed
because it can't be done then some other
decisions need to be made and I think a
committee ought to be looking at that to
ensure that you know the right decisions
are made in the right time scale this
has rolled on for far too long you can
slice it in fact I didn't know that the
decisions of dim money I can honestly
tell you that the prior chief executive
will kept on putting the latter off to
the point of friction so you know you
should understand that that there's been
something which is you know been a
concern to this committee because we
haven't enabled came through it we're
grateful to be able to get to it and so
I'll be able to have the opportunity to
ask all these questions but we are
likely in terms of a risk perspective
that we should be asking for an interim
report in November to see whether or not
you've been able to be successful in
achieving the immediate plan that you
have to recovery if you like although
not recovering income through you've
already put to me the income is fairly
robust and resilient however at that
point in November you could probably
send us some more about costs and we can
ever ring a real feel for whether it's a
profitable business or one that just in
one that is marginal or whatever then of
course there exercise gives you the
opportunity to decide whether you know
how to go forward to confirm to go
forward and and februari looks like you
know a proper business in case and I
know sorry cluttering yeah sorry it just
for me because I had my derivative a
final question old kind of way hadley
pages and everybody hope jumped in
including on sales budget apologize
that's because you dissolve I feel like
a super supportive of your question I'm
a couple I'll get was actually terrible
customer special sign I think about 10
weeks ago but i'm already generous yes
now
tell me okay I must talk to you up you
must open quickly come on man right cost
so the income is holding up even without
the staffing face that we need are you
saying this you kept holding up on the
number of staff with our agency workers
or fewer staff than you want in place at
the moment who is how many are in place
we have three in place at the moment but
we obviously have one agency member
before I came to the authority and as I
say agency staff members can be quite
costly even though I found a new agency
staff member who would be starting after
April who is a much better rank because
oh that can allow us to have a saving
although i still have capacity to get
one more in place while i'm waiting to
recruit for the permanent roles but i am
equally looking to bring down that
hourly rate as well so i'm looking to
make some cost savings again as i move
to actually that's based on pure stars
than you want in place well that's a
trajectory yeah that's a four and i'm
basing this on the floor because
obviously from the first of april so yes
so are there three in place at the
moment there are ya come was held up to
where you would expect have a yeah for
four people yes it will so as Catholics
device and got to as well nine statement
here now it hopefully it should increase
beyond the 246 32 to 36 it's based on
four and that yes again yeah I think
that's what it will be yeah yes that's
it with it i just want to come in 5.2
which we relating to costs so the
likelihood is you've got potential risk
little crystals 31,000 if the person or
through 25 sep tember 2013 into what we
refer to already so it will cost us a
Tubba 31,000 pounds to that dice keeping
those again I think that might fall I
take it I think hopefully I can allow
that fool by getting better hourly rates
but if nothing changes as of this moment
and we have the two agency staff members
at the existing costs then that's what
would cost will be by set to ember 2000
17 yeah my confusion is that its cost
31,000 pounds option September 2017 and
then oculus I think that a nickel copper
yeah that would be fantastic it was and
I think that's a typo that would be
healthy 4150 because otherwise it would
be a very good sir very very much we
like your paper oh yeah exactly yeah
just can I just reiterate on point with
my counselor Mason said in relation to
where we are with recruiting up to the
point and I think in relation to that
matter I was going to say it's a good
time to review because in case we don't
get those two permanent place posting
plates by October we may need to review
and we'll probably do that in advance
anyway if we get to that point why that
is the case is it relation to salaries
is it relation to competition between us
and other authorities doing its
benchmark do we need to see where we see
it so in comparison to them so it's
probably a sensible option if we do have
them replaced good if we don't then we
can look why and what we do at that
point okay thank you very much um
remember stay there are too many
mendation to note and ghostly tale
designs of the inhabited the process is
near maintenance preventive is us to
focus and to know that shared service in
ethics have not been issued Kevin I
wanted Lennox adds to that again you
have I hope that we would get an interim
report back in November as to progress
to date and the prognosis if you like
the opportunities then a full report
with a panic or business case for for
february's counsel award for forward
which you know will be your preferred
option which I think it ought to be and
it may be of course that you will be
decided to take me to lie big anyway if
that's
and opportunity and just like charades
just to make sure that the typo wing
thing is is that expensive and well
below it sometime like a local yes yes
was a luigi is there are now four
recommendations including those two
frightened but regarding new to report
on them but a kilo really okay thanks
very much thank you in it thank you for
more Morgan say we will revisit said
that the top of popups each year after
it said I think i'm in for the long time
right thank you vacation I'll share you
with anybody needs me from name but she
is very well by doing what you might
encounter shower things that included in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we move on to agenda item number ages of
Keaton's document if not really it's got
coffee on Phillip you think of a million
12-16 intrigue the street scene
enforcement policy in there for a while
and it's hope they will be made by the
third person charged for the next one
14-16 entre sector grounds that and the
decision issued on the 28-foot federal
1516 air quality action plan that's
combat at 31st of March I said there
because they're sort of kind of the
concentration-response is the next one
is 117 the south essex memorandum
standing the decision was issued today
stokely remember Scott okay then to 217
central announcing the community
investment plan 2017-18 to approve the
community investment plan think this one
needs on in error what's going to salem
i use that who happening one of my
colleagues put it on there and then they
realized that we had just been notified
of a younger approved it make the
decision on their give awards to make to
start and run exams yeah so so what so
having those sizes now that one which is
very communicative including one is
aware where they could call the others
preferably something wasn't that yeah
I've negative pressure text with a
freudian of what is that st. you learn
amount of money yukia to the up areas ah
got more recently especially borage
capable I try again so you know again so
we don't kill me oh it's not will avoid
now my colleagues put it on there that
actually it shouldn't be all there is
nothing to do yeah so please ignore that
one won't be on the next time mr.
omega-3 officially minutes of that
should respond very nice yes yeah yeah
probably online as well looking at seven
really there's an audit trail yesterday
it says what it comes off them so that's
fine yet we need quite interesting that
question that is the most bounce only
four years and then 317 the animal
establishment and 1963
licensed condition we go ahead and don't
fall in establishments and that's am NOT
gonna make a lot of this translation in
my own it is probably having a vigilance
committee but we've got a number of key
decisions that is being last on that
song laptop and you can practice to
exercise in are appropriate and control
is to understand all the original goals
so he could we add various andhra
president is on it twenty20 comeon oh
yeah well done I think we asked for that
a few mins going that's probably a few
mins ago and I I need to ask a bit to
make sure let's have a look that pushed
it back so let's get some new glasses
because they say how would attract all
right anyone have any question moving on
to agenda I phenomenon to work I'm
saying what we need copy abilities very
strange on time and politics product
revenue loss then next month we've got
fusion coming there's the tour of the
ledge sites next wednesday is telecom a
knee or 940 PS ecology military one
going with protective covers i think
i've got mostly respondent is apart from
one link perhaps a group of my work
program i can eat some OT decision yeah
but that's not be you know just hanging
out it'll be closer to the die cuz my
work is died died died by Cena trying so
quickly okay Justin I don't want to
leave the building without
of the day oh I'll be running down the
road behind me what we have had that I'm
afraid and it's myself through the chair
we learned also are such as possible for
that they cause I thought make it over
because when cease was good my kids and
please back to me yes probably bit like
where she works till tell you but she's
I think five blades on the radio you
should yeah yeah I think we're gonna
have ta copy that stuff so Allah peace
obscure that's when you're given the way
that they keep telling me to dig dig
diggity chemical and they're doing a
balanced later really get down button
yeah the treatment for my biggest fear
but you have any questions but got mine
among yes documentaries and some of the
other end up primarily from number 10
and exclusion of the person